Hey folks, it’s Strixhaven season. I asked my
patrons which of the new precons I should review,
and Lorehold narrowly beat out Silverquill to be
the top result. So, what’s going on with Lorehold?
I’ll get into the details later, but to start with
I’ll say that this is definitely one of the weaker
precons I’ve reviewed. That’s not necessarily
saying a lot since I’ve only reviewed seven total
and the last two were quite excellent precons, but
it does make for a fun deviation from a lot of the
more powerful precons we’ve been seeing lately.
Before I get into this precon’s key issues and
how we can go about solving them, let’s give a
quick rundown on this deck’s gameplan. The face
commander is Quintorius, History Chaser. This is
a 4 mana planeswalker with the passive ability
“Whenever one or more cards leave your graveyard,
create a 3/2 red and white Spirit creature token.”
His +1 ability reads “you may discard a card.
If you do, draw two cards, then mill a card.”
His -4 ability reads “Spirits you control gain
double strike and vigilance until end of turn.”
My first thought here is that this is actually
a pretty good package—the passive can be a good
source of bodies on board to block when paired
with other things, the +1 is a sweet source of
value, and the -4 can let the deck round the
corner and deck push toward victory after it
has been churning with leaving-graveyard synergy
for a while. Along with this excellent set of
abilities comes the downside that Quintorius,
History Chaser is a planeswalker, and can thus
be attacked by opposing creatures to get him off
the board for basically free. The implication of
this fact is that you’d want blockers to
be able to keep opposing creatures at bay,
so my first instinct is that in most cases
you’d probably want to wait an extra turn or
two to set up synergy pieces before casting
this rather than slamming it down on curve.
So, how is this deck choosing to make use out of
this command zone? Well, as far as synergies go,
there are nineteen cards that recur, exile,
or otherwise remove things from the graveyard,
along with five cards beyond the commander
that are payoffs for cards leaving the
graveyard. To pair with these, there are
twelve cards outside the commander that
help get cards into the graveyard, though
seven of these are pretty insubstantial,
so I guess we could say that there are five
cards that are proper graveyard enablers.
As an added layer of synergy, there are also
some discard payoffs, with Currency Converter,
Conspiracy Theorist, and Containment Construct
all letting the deck accumulate extra resources
off of discarded cards in some form or other,
and these can pair nicely with the commander.
As a final bit of cohesion, the deck has
19 creatures that are spirits, five other
cards beyond the commander that create spirit
tokens, and another few cards that synergize with
spirits some other way. Between this wide-ranging
synergy core, moderate counts of draw and ramp,
and a nice though somewhat more narrow span of
cards to interact with opposing plays, this deck
is looking to outgrind opponents and assemble
an army of spirits before swinging in big.
So, that’s the plan. But how is this
plan likely to work out in practice?
To start with some things I like about this
deck, there are a lot of cool gameplan elements
that work together pretty cohesively.
Leaving graveyard payoffs paired with
an assortment of different recursion
effects make for a satisfying pairing,
where you’re being rewarded for doing things
that already feel good to do. I also think the
scale of this deck’s plan for winning makes a
lot of sense—you’ve got a commander that can
churn out a lot of tokens and who can also make
those tokens hit like a truck with his -4, and
this is paired with a generally grindy gameplan
and some number of creature-buffing effects.
I even had some luck getting engines to come
together in decent time when I was doing my
test games with this precon—the average synergy
core the deck had put together at the end of turn
5 was actually better than it was with the Blight
Curse precon I reviewed a couple months ago, even
if the number of total dud games was a bit higher.
So, where do the problems of this deck come from?
Fundamentally, there are a few issues with
the way this deck functions, and the biggest
one is that it puts a lot of pressure on its
planeswalker commander to stick around on board.
As I said earlier, there are five cards in the
99 that I’d consider decent or good options for
getting cards into the graveyard, with a handful
of others that offer a weaker version of this,
and what that means is that the commander is going
to be doing a lot of heavy lifting to keep the
deck’s graveyard stocked. This feature of the deck
is compounded by its options for value generation,
which largely don’t come online that early in
the game. 7 of the 12 options I’ve categorized
under value cost five or more mana, require
some sort of setup, or more or less require
the commander to stick around in play. The
remaining options aren’t even that amazing,
containing things like Fateful Tempest that gives
opponents more agency over our fate than I’d like,
as well as Laelia who needs to be attacking
and therefore not blocking in order to generate
value. This is relevant because the commander is
a planeswalker, a card that opponents can attack
with their creatures to kill as long as they can
get around blockers. Planeswalkers are much better
in 20 health 1v1 formats because there’s only
one opponent you need to worry about swinging in,
and the lower life total means that a planeswalker
soaking up a bit of damage can be genuinely
helpful in its own right. In commander, though,
the massive life totals mean that attacking
opponents often feels barely useful anyway in
the earlier stages of the game, but attacking
a planeswalker can mean eliminating an opposing
threat without needing to spend a card. I’ve also
been in a lot of situations where an opponent
will use a removal spell on a chunky creature I
have in play to block for my planeswalker, which
then ends up making that removal spell a 2-for-1
since it lets my opponents collectively
thwack my planeswalker to death as well.
Now, all of this doesn’t mean that planeswalkers
are totally unusable in EDH, or even that a
planeswalker commander is a bad choice. This
version of Quintorius is much more powerful
than the previous creature iterations if you can
keep him around on board, and I could imagine a
universe in which you wait to play Quintorius
until you have some tools to keep him around,
or at least until you’re able to get a couple
spirits off him the same turn to block with.
The problem is, this deck isn’t designed to
do that. It usually feels clunky and awkward
without the commander, its graveyard-filling
options too sparse and its value engines too
techy and conditional. If I’m packing a hand full
of payoff, I’m gonna be wanting to run out this
bad boy as soon as possible, and that could
mean him being in a very precarious position.
This feature of the deck is worsened by its
manabase, which is honestly the most disappointing
precon manabase I’ve reviewed since the first one
I reviewed, Blame Game. Despite my best efforts,
five of my 20 test games with this deck saw a
missed early land drop, and part of the issue here
is the raw count of 37. This can be a perfectly
fine number of lands to run if you’ve got a decent
amount of early draw, filtering, or landcycling
that can dig you to more, but this deck doesn’t
really have any of these things. I honestly don’t
really understand why we’re still getting precons
with fewer than 39 lands in an era with ample
quality MDFCs and utility lands that can be
added to decks, it seems like we’re just dooming
newer players to have unnecessary manascrew games.
Beyond the raw count, the manabase is also awkward
in some other ways—its symbol counts are high due
to running a very high number of tapped-duals,
but this also means some extra clunkiness in
the early game, and there are some baffling
inclusions like Mistveil Plains, Study Hall,
and Lotus Field that add to the awkwardness.
The end effect of all of this is making the
commander’s filtering feel even more essential
for smoothing and finding land drops, and I have
to imagine this will play out poorly in practice
a lot of games. For my test games I used the rule
that Quintorius would survive the turn cycle as
long as I had one blocker for each turn past 3,
but honestly I’m pretty sure that testing
policy is not nearly conservative enough
to account for what a harsh environment an EDH
game is for planeswalkers, even at bracket 2.
Beyond the issue of overreliance on the
commander, there are a couple other things
this deck has going against it in my eyes. One
of these is an issue that sort of compounds from
the last one—a vulnerability to graveyard
hate. In theory, effects that exile your
graveyard shouldn’t be the end of the world
for this deck, since it’s looking for more
of an incremental graveyard gameplan rather than
one that builds up a massive yard full of stuff.
However, what makes it a potential issue here
is, once again, the lack of non-commander ways
to get stuff into the yard. I can easily imagine
Quintorius creeping up in command tax over time,
and though he’s pretty quick at creating a
graveyard with enough fodder to last a while,
if somebody exiles your graveyard you’re
right back to square one. This deck broadly
seems designed to be grindy and increase
in power over the course of the game,
but graveyard hate will also increase in frequency
over the game as opponents are able to access more
of their libraries, and without enough ways to
feed the graveyard I could see the late game
being a bit awkward for this deck as well. The
final issue I see here is with interaction. Some
of what’s here I don’t mind—all three of the five
mana board wipes seem pretty sweet, and there are
other cards like Skyclave Apparition and Lorehold
Charm that seem likewise well-situated. However,
the overall amount here does not impress me,
particularly for a deck that’s grindy and might
take a bit to get going. I’ve categorized 11 cards
here as interaction, but that’s probably a bit
generous given that three of the cards included in
that group are Kami of Ancient Law, White Orchid
Phantom, and Remorseful Cleric, filler spirits
with somewhat mediocre attached interactive
tools. These seem significantly more likely to be
chump blockers for Quintorius than cards actually
used against what opponents are doing, which is
fine but I feel like I’d honestly rather just
have a Wall of Omens at that point. Overall, this
interaction issue will likely be felt in this deck
struggling to slow opponents long enough to get
its own plan up and running, though I will say
that an improvement to the deck’s card economy
could help quite a bit with this all on its own.
Alright, so these are the issues I see here—too
reliant on the commander for draw and graveyard
filling, a bit vulnerable to graveyard hate, and
containing not enough interaction. So, how do we
go about fixing these things? Well, weakness
to graveyard hate is tied in with the deck’s
graveyard feeding, and quantity of available
interaction is tied into the deck’s card economy,
so we’re really going to be focused on these
first two. Let’s start with cuts. This deck has
some kinda-filler two and three cost creatures,
and while I see the desire to have blockers,
I just can’t get fully on board with these. Kami
of Ancient Law and White Orchid Phantom are some
two drop spirits I mentioned earlier and don’t
really care for. If you’re gonna have a phantom
in your deck, you could at least have the decency
to pair it with an indestructible land and try to
convince me it’s ramp. Another cut is Naktamun
Lorespinner—this is probably going to be a very
cool piece of tech in eternal formats, but in a
grindy EDH deck with a value engine commander,
it feels out of place. Another cut is going to
be Drumbellower—this is far from a bad card,
but it feels pretty underutilized here
given that the commander’s -4 already
offers vigilance on any turn you’d want to swing
wide. Moving along to higher-cost creatures,
I’m cutting the two Neon Dynasty dragons.
These are also perfectly fine cards,
but they kinda just seem like blockers here,
and I’m not particularly sold on their beatdown
potential with Quintorius’s -4 either. This deck
is stacked with powerful five drops, so I’m also
cutting Karmic Guide and Balefire Liege. The
former is a passable recursion spell, and the
latter is a guy that buffs the board but doesn’t
do a whole lot else. Finally, as noncreature cuts,
we’re axing Fateful Tempest and Monologue Tax. The
latter is kinda a poor ramp spell in general IMHO,
and though I see the appeals of Fateful
Tempest, I dislike its unreliability,
and I also wanted to cut a noncreature spell
to avoid having our creature count dip too low.
Now, for the additions, ten cards that each cost
$3 or less. To start with, I want to see a couple
MDFCs in here to make sure we’re hitting our
land drops. Witch Enchanter is a no-brainer
for a deck that doesn’t have a whole ton of
noncreature permanent removal at the moment,
and Makindi Stampede feels nice as a way to
replace the spirit-buffing of Balefire Liege.
Next up, let’s get a whole bunch more draw
and filtering in here. From the main set,
I’m pulling Ark of Hunger—cool ass card name
and art, by the way—and Pursue the Past,
both of which help fill our graveyard and generate
card advantage. Something I’ve been noticing more
and more is Wizards of the Coast including fairly
obvious additions to precons within the main set,
which seems nice as a way to get newer
players started in tuning their decks.
Another filtering spell I’m adding is
Fear of Missing Out, which is a nice
blocker that can offer some crazy alpha-strike
potential with Quint’s -4 later in the game,
since that loyalty ability also gives vigilance.
Tersa Lightshatter is another addition with a
similar profile—an immediate burst of filtering,
a blocker in the short term, and a value engine
once your graveyard hits threshold. Brass’s Tunnel
Grinder also fits this mold, not including a body
to block with but being an even better filtering
tool and an even better value engine later in the
game. As a sixth and final filtering addition,
we’re adding good ol’ Plargg. I love that we
get to include the Lorehold flip Dean from the
previous Strixhaven set, and a two drop creature
who can tap to rummage is exactly what this
deck is looking for. Alright, now that we’ve
eaten our vegetables with these first eight, I
have two more “fun” additions. On Wings of Gold
is an enchantment printed in the Aetherdrift
zombie precon, and its appeals are simple—it’s
an extra leaving-graveyard payoff, and more
importantly it gives our spirits +1/+1 and flying,
further improving this deck’s ability to punch in
for damage. For my final addition, I’m adding the
flip card Mila and Lukka. The front side is
a nice fox friend to help defend Quintorius,
and the backside is a top-end planeswalker that
plays nicely into the deck’s graveyard themes.
Alright, those are my 10 cuts and additions.
Overall, this precon is operating in some fun
mechanical territory, and this style of red white
deck is really unique and deserves to be seen
more. It also does “feel” pretty Lorehold to me,
and I like that we still manage to get a few new
arts for cards even in a set with five precons.
Also, with this set we’ve finally finished the
tango and bicycle land cycles, after 11 and
9 years, respectively. Budget typed dual land
enjoyers, rejoice! So, I broadly don’t mind this
precon, or even the fact that it has some issues
that make it a bit suboptimal. That said, I would
prefer that precons steer away from the sorts of
issues that make it likely for them to stall out:
not enough lands, overreliance on the commander,
and especially not enough filtering. What I mean
by filtering is cards that prioritize letting you
see more of your library over value or increasing
your total card pool. This phrase accurately
describes five of my ten additions, even if four
of these are also capable of being value-positive,
and the appeal of these in something like a precon
is very straightforward: seeing more of your deck
is good! Seeing more of your deck lets you play
more of your deck, put together more interesting
combinations of cards from within your deck, and
if nothing else lay your eyes on and hold within
your fingers a greater proportion of the cardboard
that exists within your deck. That is going to be
enjoyable for most decks, but it’s especially
important for precons. Imbuing players with a
sense of agency should be the #1 goal there, and
that’s what friends like Plargg are here for.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to Archidekt
for supporting the channel. Archidekt’s
multi-layered category system makes it easy
for me to dig into decks like I did here,
and the maybeboard categories system is perfect
for displaying something like additions and cuts.
A link to my upgrade of this precon is in the
description. If you’re in the market for high
quality sleeves with a great variety of different
colors and designs, you can pick yourself up some
Dragonshield sleeves at my affiliate link in the
description, using code “salubrious” for 5% off.
If you want to support me more directly, you
can sign up for my Patreon, or sign up for a
YouTube membership. Those lovely people get
bonus videos from me once a month or so, and
some of them get to be featured in my credits as
well. Don’t you want to see your name on screen?